[Music]
god i feel
sick don't like this at all
this porcelain [ __ ] is the worst kind
of news
i know i'll be careful not exactly one
of your strong suits
listen first sign of trouble be delta
she emptied the place [ __ ]
excellent you have come
thanks for meeting me of course v
and i thank you before we discuss
details
i feel i owe you an explanation i must
tell you
why i changed my mind and wish to help
weren't sure of anything if you could
trust me
if your nobody killed your father now
i knew from the start you
knew all the board members knew
not one soul even slightly interested in
the matter believed in the poisoning
details were disparate inconsistent
you knew but didn't do a thing about it
why suddenly sprouted conscience just
yesterday
my father had flaws i know this
i harbor no illusions about it
when a phone needed removal my father
ordered it without
a thought to mercy a way of being
yorinobu could not abide but to my
father
ends ever justified means
saburu arasaka has always valued just
one thing
do you know what it is
power family
our family i was to be its heart
to uphold life ensure continuity
stability never to oppose it
oh i guess your nobis instructions were
a little different
yorinobu raised his hand against our
father
but he is an arasaka he is family
i do not expect you to understand i
wish you merely to know i do not oppose
my brother willingly
that it is difficult
he's your brother it's been hard it'll
be hard
let's say i get that what changed your
mind
we received a warning during the parade
security protocols were violated
the first doubts sprouted then
they grew yet greater in your hideout
when my brother's assault group arrived
not to rescue
but to kill your nobu is just plain
willing to sacrifice you
my father was right about my brother
he never cared for us i was brought up
to be the heart
of the family it is time for the
arasakas to listen to their heart
it will bring justice did you bring soul
killer
as we agreed you finger on the trigger
don't say a word
seem on edge something guy you spooked
i don't know
three times now that av has flown by
think someone might have tailed you
we must not get distracted did you bring
soul killer
take me for a fool think i'd fall for
that got plans to walk out of here alive
had i any ill intentions i would have
chosen a side far more discreet
than this we are here because i know how
to save your life
i can lead you to mikoshi
meaning mikushi don't exist in real
space
yet its access points do and one is very
near
where here in night city
beneath arasaka tower
we ought to leave right now
wanna leave what gave you that idea
quit button in so i can hear her out
this is gonna be a disaster sit
we have little time
and you'll help me in exchange for
my brother you catch a whiff of that
smells like [ __ ]
careful not to step in it he must be
made to take responsibility
for his deeds
sounds like you want to avenge dead old
dad
i want the arasaka corporation to know
the truth how you plan to do this
will soon call a meeting of the board
representatives of all
factions are expected to attend
the perfect moment for them to learn the
circumstances of my father's death
i will get you into this meeting and
you will testify against my brother
testify listen mind if i'm straight with
you
help me get rid of your enough i will
help you get rid of the construct
and i will need to return to the estate
soon
so as not to raise any suspicions
don't like this at all sounds like you
want to use me
no i simply offer you an opportunity
not the first to try but what if i am
the last
you cannot take that chance let's fly
the [ __ ] out of here
v do you feel all right
huh you are bleeding
[ __ ] it seems you are running out of
time
don't delay make your decision
uh i'll think it over
you could use some air right now
[Music]
you can't stand on your own two feet
well i'm good to go
buddy listens to me
[Applause]
see what i'm getting at
of course i can see you want me to
handle
the keys i want to save your life
pop some pseudo-endotriesey scooch and
let me get behind the wheel
i'll get us to [ __ ] mikoshi yeah
how exactly without that porcelain
cunt's help
that's for damn sure don't stand a
chance without help
right about that but that's why i'll
bring rogue
she's not rusted through just yet
plus she owes me maybe she just stuck
her neck out for you
half a century ago but now i don't see
it
i'll convince her after all we know a
thing or two about ops like this
we'll blast our way into soccer tower
just like we did
back in the day then find the way inside
mikoshi
it's our only chance what about pan
am she offered help
listen i know you and pan am got a thing
going
i get it i do but that's what makes it
such a shitty
idea you don't want to rope her into
this
made the same mistake myself once
you don't want those people involved
their lives on the line
possibly on your conscience
our one hope is sitting at the afterlife
right now and her name is
rogue gotta stop you [ __ ]
what's your scheme this is my body i
make the call just this time
oh johnny jesus look at you can't even
great you checking out again
what am i
no it's not what you think not yet
easy there don't move just yet
[Music]
vic you're in pain i know
delirious when you arrive so i had a
dozen with beta haloperidol
but light over sensitivity is a good
sign means your optic nerves aren't
damaged
my head ah almost done
stabilizing the biochip oh it feels like
someone's using your head as a knife
block
how how'd i get here
dragged yourself here beat the hell and
back
you missed your hell of a fright
then you shoved my patient at the time
off the table
and demanded you be treated immediately
delimit was your guardian angel huh
i uh i wasn't completely myself
i know and that's a bit worrying
just give it to me straight vic
you've come to a critical juncture
try sitting up carefully
[Music]
okay don't expect a miracle
slowly
another victory for the history books
[Music]
well looks like i can sit up all right
but i can tell you don't have good news
how much longer is this going to go on
you tell me looking at you not long at
all
next attack you will be able to crawl
back here you'll flatline in some back
alley
this is your last chance to take matters
into your own hands
understand
i know vic i'll try
soon no you'll do it now
now see that setup over there
yeah what about it you'll find the last
dose of pseudo-endotries in there
a gift from misty want to give in to the
voices in your head
go ahead take a puff go silent
get out or
find another way and things on your own
turns
got a little present for me over there
too blockers
manage to walk those few yards to the
table
the rest will be up to you and you alone
you heard him we've got one last chance
i'm taking the wheel
endotriezine rogue soccer tower
only way this is gonna work
enough johnny i just
gotta think about it i need to stretch
your new little
fine just no it's not in this basement
christ you're talking out loud
how loud what
just go fix this thing uh
i think i can do it
whatever you can thank you enough for
all your time get out of here first
i only wish i could have done more go on
now
i don't want to close up take the meds
do what you got to do thanks vic
i will and you hang in there too
good luck
[Music]
hey v i heard well
your thoughts you shouldn't have had to
sorry about that no need to be
i know what's going on and i know it
won't be easy
for either of you if you don't want to
decide here
i know a much better place
sure lead the way why is this spot
special
i took jackie there once it's not far
jackie what's he got to do with any of
this
you'll see come on
top floor
he had the same glum face oh
jack this is it chica
i'm done for doesn't sound like the
jackie i knew
that was a long time ago his mom had
just found out he'd signed up with the
valentinos
trust me senora wells on one shoulder
your gang chumba is on the other no
choice can ever seem right
life wasn't easy for my jackie but
he found the courage to bet on himself
after i brought him here
ah that's more like it air
see that
i come here when i need to get away be
alone with my thoughts
she's on to something ought to sit mull
through some [ __ ] yourself
thanks misty you were right choice spot
so what what did jackie decide of here
oh you know gonna be a legend in this
city
and i'm gonna leave you alone now
take your time
[ __ ] scared me know that thought you
were on your way out
no i'm still here for now
you know should call anyone you want to
say goodbye to
worst case scenario now would you expect
no but whatever you decide risk's gonna
be high
if things don't go our way just [ __ ]
do it
anyone you gotta talk to now's the time
pills can wait
no not really my style goodbyes
you do you come a long way to get here
heavenly
just think it all started in a [ __ ]
landfill
then you tried to kill me see exactly
what i mean
trying to save your sorry hide now
you can let me do that or you can try
pan am and hurt tarmac rats
but then their lives will lay heavy on
your soul
where you take arasaka's deal but then
you'll have your own soul on your
conscience
i'm gonna try to ask pan am for help
you absolutely sure no going back on
this you
i'm know try this with panam
got a feeling you're gonna regret this
decision
and the moment that dawns i won't be
there to help
could be my last ride this don't work
out uh
just want to be there for it where
see you inside mikoshi
[Music]
johnny okay
just me now
hey bannon do you know what time it is
i know but need your help
and you owe me a favor what's so damn
urgent i couldn't wait until
morning need a way into our socket tower
now sorry what
i'm serious whole thing with johnny i
don't do something soon i'm done
gone slow down first
why are a soccer tower the tech
underneath that tower they got an access
point too
whoa odd as it sounds
a prison of souls a
prison of souls this might not fly over
the hollow
mikoshi that's his name only place
johnny and i can disentangle for good
it's my last chance so
again just to be clear you've called me
at high moon to ask me to help you break
into arasaka tower
or
can you hold off on dying for a bit give
it a shot sure
good don't go anywhere i'm coming to get
you
[Music]
so
is that uv or
yeah it's me so
what now waiting for my driver
come inside we'll wait together
[Music]
since you have to wait mind if i give
you a reading
so why not some believe uncertainty
is an evil that should be dispelled
through divination
others claim it's change that is evil
but that isn't true either
every minute of every day we each become
someone new
we shouldn't fear change itself but only
who we might change into
knowing one's path is most important
i devised this layout especially for you
and johnny
your future is his future and vice versa
okay i'm ready
we'll start with you
the fool what a surprise
let's dig deeper to find its meaning
here
the fool symbolizes the start of a
journey the announcement of something
new
it's the inner child curious of the
world but also
naive and reckless sounds a lot like the
v
i first met the magician
a person of great talent and charisma a
leader
sounds like johnny a card is reversed
that can mean a tendency toward
addiction mental instability
okay definitely johnny he is one great
disturbance
the final cards are about your futures
the lovers something that doesn't give
me the chills
finally balance friendship
love v
have you been keeping something from me
huh
what why you're making a strange face
i uh no
i'm fine okay and johnny's
the moon well it doesn't sound too bad
right
i don't know v the moon
is mystery
hmm i think that's for you
yep no mistaking that ride ever
[Music]
you've scared me you know that
didn't think anything could scare you
hey we're here to help okay
come on everybody's waiting again
look out for yourself
[Music]
welcome back to the living you feeling
okay
what happened you passed out on the way
we tried shaking you awake to no avail
sure does seem like your condition might
be getting worse v
pan am asked me to keep an eagle eye on
you where'd she go
she's off debating saul you need help
that's clear
they sat right down to figure out how we
might do that
come on i'll take you to see him
so v i